san copa is designed to support the
retention and recruitment of black
students at nevada state college here to
tell us more about their summer bridge
program is dr chartrea collier she's the
director of sankofa and shania johnson
she is a student how are you guys doing
doing well how are you today excellent
thank you for joining us let's start off
with the meaning of the word sankofa
what does it mean sankofa means learning
from our past to protect our future i
love it yes and it's from the ghanaian
tui language actually so what does what
does the program entail so sankofa
basically we have several different
components but our summer bridge program
is a two-week program for students they
receive mentorship from faculty they
receive several sessions about college
success they receive field trips they
get an opportunity to learn a little bit
more about black las vegas and to do a
little bit of community service as well
i love it shania how has the program
helped you out it's extremely important
to establish community early on
especially when you're fresh and going
into college for the first time um
meeting all those people and all the
field trips and everything it was just
so engaging and fun and made me really
look forward to going into college as a
black student like um to see myself and
my community being represented in such a
way it was just it's so i love sankofa
it's inspiring it is i'm inspired just
hearing your story so what kind of what
field do you want to get into i want to
get more so into the media aspect like
making short films like i love being
creative in this way like
um and sankofa has really helped me and
um supported me in that way well
and the minute you've been on the show
you're natural in this business i tell
you that much you are natural they can
see it through the camera right now are
there scholarships that you that you
guys offer absolutely so the students
receive a 250 stipend for participating
however if they decide to come to nevada
state college they receive a 2500
scholarship so we do activities or what
kind of topics do you guys tackle during
the summer program that's a great
question so one of the things we do is
give students an overview of all of the
different careers that are available to
them so for example i'm in education so
we have several faculty members who
present on career pathways and education
we also have a phenomenal nursing school
at nevada state college so we have
presentations on nursing we have
presentations on black people in stem so
again the focus is social justice and
also particularly looking at people of
african descent and their contributions
in these various different uh careers
people watching right now i think they
want to get involved in two ways first
off how does a student get involved and
take advantage of this well first of all
if you're a student out there who might
be interested in our program then we
certainly want you to reach out to us
and apply but for faculty community
members we love to have community
involved we actually have a position for
a community member we want people to one
of the key parts of this program is
leadership so we want people from the
community to come and share their
expertise they can also participate in
these programs they can provide
workshops and so if they're interested
then by all means reach out to sankofa
nsc.edu we love it you're doing amazing
things i love this thank you so much for
joining us today we truly appreciate it
and then one day i'll be working for you
i'm sure you'll be my boss be nice to me
when you're my boss okay i'll bring this
interview up thank you so much uh
jillian will send everybody